Привет! За 7 уроков мы собрали уже и брифы, и конкурентный анализ, аудит, персоны, провели интервью. В общем, много данных, много инсайтов и проблема тут одна. Из этого пока не следует, что вообще конкретно это нужно делать. В брифах одни фичи, в инсайтах персон другие, в конкурентном анализы TableStay, которые вроде как тоже нужны в интервью EdgeCases, которые хочется учесть. Если бы пытаться впихнуть всё в первую версию, получится раздущий.
продукт, который, скорее всего, никогда не выйдет. Поэтому нужно отфильтровать, что идёт в MVP, а что будет у нас потом. Для этого есть Moscow — это простой фреймворк приоритизации. Как расшифровывается Moscow? Итак, у нас тут 4 категории. Must have — без этого запускаться смысла нет. Should have — это важно, но запуститься можно и без этого. Третье — could have — полезно, если хватит времени. И последнее — won't have now. Осознанно откладываем пока что в бэклог. Тут ключевое — это не то, что
там бесполезно. Это то, что важно, но пока можно и без этого обойтись. Агент прочитает все файлы проекта и сделает три вещи: соберет фичи, расставит приоритеты и сформулирует scope MVP. Сейчас покажу.
Сейчас покажу. За один запуск директивы делает всё, собирает фичи из всех артефактов, приоритизирует и формулирует scope. Так она выглядит. Как обычно, здесь расписаны все шаги, название файлов, куда нужно сохранить. Видим уже, что у нас три артефакта будет.
Как обычно, перекидываем просто в чатик и запускаем. Итак, первые два он сделал, можем начать сразу с фичерс-лист, посмотреть из чего он состоит. Тут у нас полный список фич, каждая из них с названием, описанием, источником и персоной, для которой она критична.
Обратите внимание на столбец источник, здесь видно откуда пришла фича. Из брифа, инсайтов персоны, конкурентного анализа или интервью. Это важно, фичи из разных источников имеют разный вес.
Фича, которая пришла из job to be done primary person, скорее всего must have. Фича какой-нибудь secondary персоны в интервью это уже should have или could have.
Также там фича из конкурентного анализа с пометкой table stakes это must have, без нее продукт всерьез не воспримут и так далее.
Конечно, если агент что-то не то написал, если вы с чем-то не согласны, убирайте, добавляйте, это все-таки ваш проект, за вами конечное решение.
Следующий файл это приоритизация. Также через превью его откроем, посмотрим, что у нас здесь есть.
Тут у нас документ, разбитый по Москву, четыре таблички с фичами, которые по четырем группам разделяются.
Как мы ранее обсуждали, must have, should have и так далее. То, без чего запуск невозможен, то, что стоит добавить,
то, чем можно пока пренебречь и то, что вообще у нас уходит в бэклог.
И последний файлик это MVP scope. Давайте его также откроем.
Этот файлик начинается у нас с одного предложения, что это за продукт и что он делает в MVP.
Обязательно прочитайте его, если звучит размыто, значит попросите агента его переформулировать.
Это очень важно. Это предложение вы будете использовать на каждой встрече, в каждом обсуждении.
Оно должно быть четким. Дальше у нас список фич для MVP. Это, соответственно, must have из предыдущего документа.
Он также по функционалу приложения разбит.
Также включен основной сценарий MVP, путь primary, персоны от входа до результата, какие шаги, какие экраны, какой итог.
Также тут расписаны экраны MVP и что осознанно в MVP не входит.
Несмотря на то, что Telegram уведомления у нас неоднократно всплывали,
именно для MVP нам будет достаточно email рассылки.
Telegram это круто.
Мы его добавим уже в следующей итерации.
Итак, все три файла в нашем проекте в следующем уроке агент подтянет их при генерации PRD.
В качестве домашнего задания точно так же запускаем директиву, скриним, что у нас эти файлики действительно есть.
Присылаем в качестве изображения при сдаче домашней работы.
И здесь в MVP scope идем в самый конец и смотрим три вот эти фичи, которые осознанно в MVP не войдут.
Это три фичи, которые имеют достаточно высокий приоритет.
Это важные штуки, но осознанно они в MVP не войдут.
И мне интересно будет почитать, насколько вы согласны с тем перечнем,
который ваш агент решил не включать в MVP версию приложения.
На этом все. Увидимся в следующем уроке.
Это будет кульминация модуля.
Мы все соберем в красивый PRD документ.
Увидимся в следующем уроке.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
Пока.